because i feel like some some youtubers
who i've met who
their youtube is so intertwined with not
not not only their job but their
self-worth as well yeah
and it's like if i'm not successful on
youtube then i'm not successful as a
person
i'd say though it was like the first
time i started to feel like i was
looking at it like a job was like really
scary
because i was like am i losing my touch
like am i going to be a bad youtuber now
yeah because i'm not i'm not like
thinking about it 24 7. yeah
the first few months i was really
struggling to like kind of just
understand that like it's okay to like
not
think about this all the time right yeah
um yeah and then now i feel like i have
a pretty healthy balance with it where i
don't
honestly don't really think about it
that much i kind of plan what i need to
do
i think it also helps as well that like
especially you and i have really like
gone down in terms of like how sporadic
we upload because like we used to upload
way more frequently now yeah you should
try and do two a week and then
i used to be daily dude yeah daily is
like i don't know how you do that but
yeah i went from daily to i went from
daily to weekly you know so
[ __ ] psychos
i mean joey at the time like yeah you
did upload daily i was like three times
a week
but that's what youtube wanted back then
yeah yeah yeah three times a week i
don't think would work now
it would be unoptimized yeah i think i'm
at a point now like
maxine i think i'm at a point now where
like i just upload like
uh like once a week i think the audience
has changed i think audiences would just
rather get something
well i think i think two weeks is kind
of long but one week just a good video
once a week and it seems to do the job
yeah no pretty much because it's so
saturated now
yeah and there's so much trouble gives
me a lot of time to just live my life
rather that because
youtube's kind of weird i feel like
people kind of uh go on either side of
the spectrum it's either
like it's like the business versus like
the artist if you
are too far into the artist then you
kind of lose focus on like how your
business is doing
and some people don't care about that
which is fine but then you get people
who like care about the numbers way too
much
and then it kind of integrates into
their life and their self-worth and
even just the people that they hang out
with like unless they're a big youtuber
i won't hang out with them
kind of thing definitely
like that side like i've seen that so
frequently which is why like i'm like
okay i don't
i don't want to fall into that so i
decided to back up and just
make my own private life really
infuriates me when i've had
people who i thought were good friends
and then maybe i like introduce them to
one of my friends and they're not like a
youtuber and they'll be like i don't
care who they are yeah
i think that's the biggest tell for me
where especially because you know
whenever we travel
or something like that we always try to
bring our friends with us right even if
they're not
youtubers or doing something else if
they're peasants
if we bring them along it's funny
normies there's commoners
imagine working in an office job i'm
joking
you know like we always hear it as a
kind of a joke but it's true sometimes
you
i i hate saying it like this but
remember the little people but more like
remember your roots
go back to that and like i just i just
think because normally youtubers tend to
hang out with other youtubers because
like the lifestyle is similar yeah i
mean like you're just there and that's
fine like you can make youtuber friends
i just don't like it when people like
yeah and it's obvious like you it's so
obvious
a lot of the times where it's like oh hi
like you know when they start like
sucking another big youtuber's dick so
hard like to the point it's just like
then the point like what is the point of
that friendship if all you ever want is
just like your friendship only exists on
youtube but if it doesn't exist
like outside of youtube then it's like
because for me like the tel the telltale
sign of that might be happening with
someone that i know is when
the only times that will ever dm me is
for a youtube club and that's where i'm
just like
oh okay like you don't give a [ __ ] about
me at all
yeah i've had a few messages where it's
like it's really obvious that
the only time they message is when they
need something which is also why i very
rarely do collabs on my channel
the people i've done collabs on my
channel is people like i genuinely had
like a connection with
because i'm very much a person that will
show their emotions on camera
because i'm not gonna fake anything so
like for example just recently i just
collaborated with charlotte and emma but
those are two people that i've been
friends with for years and just recently
have i felt comfortable enough to
actually do a video with them yeah
that's if anyone wanted to know why i
don't collaborate with that many
youtubers that's why and it's also the
introvert in me
any introvert will understand that like
we keep the
people like we're very picky with people
but the people that we do pick we keep
very tightly
yeah yeah you're very much like the
opposite to me on that i'm like
yeah same i'm like hell yeah come on
let's go let's go hang out yeah but like
and that's fine like i just you know
it's so easy for me it's easier because
then i just know like what people i
already know want to hang out
like at night but when there's too many
people i feel like man i gotta balance
everyone out and then i don't
like it's too many people it's hard to
maintain yeah a little bit
just for me i just hope that like you
know the people i make friends
with that like you know they're they
don't expect me to like the actual
friends i actually
don't expect anything out of it yeah
like they understand if we're like we're
both busy you know
yeah yeah i don't know like uh yeah it's
it's not about like you know i'm friends
with this person to get
something out yeah exactly because for
me i
don't do collabs on my channel at all or
that's just because my content i felt
doesn't really lend well to collabs
especially since like it's very scripted
content so
i just want to hang out with people i
don't care i'd like never care about the
collabs that's
never in my mind i just like meeting new
people well that's the thing right it's
like
you know i probably only collapsed with
like half the youtubers i actually have
become friends with yeah that's just
purely because some youtubers i know
where it's like
it doesn't matter how much i bend this
concept of like anime content
there's just no way i can integrate
their personality what they're about
into the content
yeah and you know nothing against the
youtubers i know it's just it's just how
the content
not even against collabs because you
know watching you guys collab i'm just
like man that seems kind of fun
let's see it is fun it's really fun and